vor 13,8 milliarden jahren ist das
universum wohl entstanden und zwar mit
dem urknall das war der anfang
das gilt als gesichert doch wie sieht
sein tod aus wie wird das universum wohl
zu ende gehen dazu gibt es verschiedene
theorien mal droht dem universum ein
dunkles und leeres und kaltes schicksal
mal stirbt es von einer sekunde auf die
andere
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
messenger gewünscht und bekommt jetzt
die fünf spannendsten szenarien zum
absoluten finale des universums so oder
so es wird spektakulär herzlich
willkommen bei pixum science fiction
seit seiner entstehung und dem urknall
dehnt sich das universum aus und es gibt
vereinfacht gesagt zwei kräfte die sein
schicksal bestimmen zum einen der
schwung des urknalls der es
auseinandertreibt und zum anderen die
materie die sich in ihm befindet und
seine expansion abbremst wie wird es
enden welche kraft wird gewinnen
doch neben diesen beiden kräften
existierte aber noch die hypothetische
dunkle energie forschungsteams weltweit
verstehen sie noch nicht wirklich doch
sie agiert wohl wie eine art anti
schwerkraft die das universum
auseinandertreibt zudem wird sie wohl
umso größer je mehr sich der raum aus
denen eventuell wird ja auch diese
mysteriöse dunkle energie in zukunft
übermächtig dann würde sie nicht nur
sterne und galaxien aufeinander reisen
sondern auch atome und moleküle und zwar
so lange bis nur noch strahlung und und
zerlegbare teilchen existieren hier
kommen für euch jetzt fünf weitere
spannende theorien zum ende des
universums szenario eins der big trick
fangen wir an mit dem sogenannten big
trick demnach befindet sich das weltall
in einem meter stabilen zustand quasi
wie ein ball der zwischen zwei bergen im
tal hin und her rollt wie zieht man dann
die quantenphysik mit 1 ist dieser ball
allerdings nicht nur in diesem einen
teil stattdessen gibt es ihn in allen
tälern dieser welt nach einer gewissen
wahrscheinlichkeit verteilung
theoretisch wäre es also auch möglich
dass er sich sehr plötzlich in einem
deutlich tieferen teil befindet und darf
ohne zeitverlust genau dieses szenario
sich auch auf das universum übertragen
solch einen phasenübergang ist
statistisch gesehen sogar jederzeit
möglich und er passiert einfach so quasi
von selbst weil der erreichte zustand
energetisch gesehen günstiger ist denn
auch wenn wir menschen den jetzigen
zustand als grundzustand empfinden ist
es wahrscheinlich dass ein noch
geringeres energieniveau existiert beim
beispiel des balles also ein noch
tieferes tal teams aus teilchen
physikern und physikerin vermuten sogar
dass solch einen phasenübergang bereits
schon einmal stattgefunden hat und zwar
milliardstel sekunden nach dem urknall
als einig fällt den raum gefüllt hat
durch die interaktion von explosionen
und elementarteilchen haben die teilchen
dann erst ihre masse bekommen
doch wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass
demnächst erneut ein phasenübergang
stattfindet dazu haben
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus dänemark bereits 2013 geforscht in
ihrer studie ging es vor allem um die
frage wie stabil der grund zustand des
universums ist ihre ergebnisse lassen
darauf schließen dass es sich
tatsächlich deutlich stärker auf der
instabilen seite befindet als man bisher
dachte
und das lässt die wahrscheinlichkeit
eines solchen phasen übergangs natürlich
ansteigen doch ihre forschung gibt nicht
eins zu eins antwort auf die frage wie
das universum ende denn in ihren
berechnungen stecken einige
unsicherheiten beispielsweise was die
dunkle materie und die dunkle energie
angeht das ist ja absolut nicht
gesichert ob und wie sie existieren für
beide gab es bisher keinerlei nachweise
sie sind hypothetisch zweite szenario
der kältetod
einige fachleute sind der ansicht dass
sich das universum immer schneller
aussehen für das wir in etwa 13
milliarden jahren nichts mehr außer
unseren nachbarn galaxien im universum
sehen werden kleine objekte die
milchstraße und die magellanschen wolken
beispielsweise werden lang miteinander
verschmelzen und schwarze löcher bilden
zudem wird es immer weniger sterne geben
das alles basiert auf der annahme dass
unser universum durch die sogenannte
kosmologische konstante dominiert wird
diese wurde von albert einstein ins
leben gerufen damit seine allgemeine
relativitätstheorie tatsächlich ein
statisches universum
so wie gewünscht denn zu seiner zeit war
man sich einig dass sich das universum
wieder zusammenzieht noch aus sind
einige zeit später erkannte man dann
dass sich das weltall doch ausdehnt und
die konstante wurde zwischenzeitlich
abgeschafft mittlerweile hat man sie ins
standardmodell der kosmologie
zurückbefördert dabei ist man sich
allerdings immer noch uneinig ob sie
tatsächlich konstant ist dritte szenario
der begriff einer dritten theorie
zufolge könnte das universum auch durch
einen sogenannten big rig sterben und
zwar wenn sich das universum so krass
aus den dass es quasi zerrissen wird
in der theorie könnte das tatsächlich so
passieren nämlich dann wenn die dunkle
energie einen noch extremeren negativen
druck aufweist als wir bisher annehmen
doch es gibt auch einige fakten die
gegen den begräbt als das große finale
des universums sprechen vierte szenario
der blick wann das große knirschen den
modellen namens big crunch zufolge
könnte genau das gegenteil von big wird
passieren das universum würde sich den
markt zusammen ziehen und dann
schlussendlich in einem and knall enden
es würde also immer enger werden das
universum quasi als eine art kosmische
schrottpresse und zwar bis es so heiß
und nicht wäre wie zu zeiten des
urknalls dafür sind zwei voraussetzungen
nötig einen phasenübergang müsste dafür
sorgen dass die dunkle energie
verschwindet und sich in materie
umwandelt außerdem müsste das universum
eine positive krümmung aufweisen denn
dann würde die materie die ausdehnung
des universums in eine kontraktion
verwandeln was ist wirklich zum big
crunch kommen würde könnte danach ein
big points stattfinden also wieder ein
urknall der einen neuen zyklus des
universums beginnen lassen würde fünfte
szenario unfall mit einem nachbar
universum möglich ist auch dass das
universum vor seinem natürlichen tod
einen unfall hat und mit einem nachbar
universum zusammenstößt es gibt
fachleute die davon ausgehen dass so
etwas in regelmäßigen abständen passiert
ein physiker von der princeton
university beispielsweise ist der
meinung das ganze in unserer nähe ein
zweites universum in höheren
raumdimensionen existiert demnach ist
der urknall lediglich die innenansicht
einer kollision mit unserem zwillings
und
also um eine weitere kollision in
zukunft würde für einen neuen
lebenszyklus des universums sorgen an
all diesen szenarien wird weiter gefeilt
noch ist rein gar nichts sicher alles
hypothesen gedankenspiele usw
und sobald indizien für die ein oder
andere theorie veröffentlicht werden
erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier wenn ihr
kein video dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die etwas
unzuverlässige abo box sie auf youtube
und ihr verpasst kein video denn über
whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
vornehmen upload und zwar noch vor allen
anderen täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt dafür hier klicken
aber nicht die genau locker vergessen
heute es geht es übrigens um den
gefängnis blogger hier in berlin also im
aktuellen video ja und hier geht es war
damit dafür auch darauf blicken ist das
universum ein supercomputer bis dann
bleibt dran